hey guys merry kiss here along with my
great pal Chris water hey Mary hey an e3
2014 we just got done on the show floor
playing evolve yeah we got some new new
monsters the Kraken the Kraken is out
and I pregnant you knew those are good
if they're like this and I played as a
medic so there's a lot new things to see
that they're displaying on the show
floor now so once you tell me a little
bit about cracking oh man finds you
always thought like peripherals got all
these things he's got all these
different abilities right Goliath is the
one we've seen a lot that's sort of the
hulking like stomping their fire breath
like palps attacks like rocks throwing
like kind of a brute force in the mix
character right the Kraken does not have
as much armor does not have as much
health but you can fly and so so you
kind of pop up you jump and then you
basically hover and you can sort of dash
to the side you can drop down but your
your your skills thrive at range you
want to you can throw lightning bolts as
sort of your basic melee attack when
you're in the air but a lot of your
stuff is electricity based so you can
call down this lightning strike that's
kind of like Pikachu and smash brothers
but it's like Nick and then like what
like comes down but it's a little touchy
so you kind of got to line it up but
when you do and actually the developers
telling me a fully charged up lightning
strike is the most powerful of the
monster ability in the game at this
point I'm incapacitate two guys each had
half health with one shot oh so good it
is good when you know the things that
you're shooting off actually did have a
dead hit I was uh one of the sad people
medic that got hit with a full blast and
not only you know doesn't suck your help
but actually shoots you backwards pretty
far and the whole point about this
monster I believe you know he kind of
swoops in and he gets a few jabs in and
then he's out the problem with this is
that you you can get him down to one bar
but if you leave
you gotta go follow him and catch him
and he's real fast and he's quick and it
can be sort of elusive with the flying
and dashing the end to your point about
sort of knockback attacks that's such a
key strategy for monsters and there's
this other attack called the vortex
blast or something I don't know
basically what it looks like a
corkscrews at the hunters and then just
knocks them off like bowling pins that
does less damage but it flings you
further and so that's like you know
that's the you guys go over here like if
you hit them with a warp vortex blast
here and then you can press B to sort of
drop from the sky do some serious melee
damage to one of the one of the
characters and then when you're you know
when they come then bring their full
force to bear on you you can get in
trouble as the Kraken but then you just
sort of jump up you throw down some of
these mines you're talking about they
home in and they're actually the big
like red balls and so they come slowly
at your face it's distracting and weird
as the hunters to deal with so that's
sort of all you're you're like crowd
control and like hit and run count of
tactics and the Cowardly way to go about
this or such a brutal on fairy broken
like a true person who got eaten by
monster marriage okay I don't have as
much experience being a monster okay
you're talking about how to play the
monster a lot oh yeah totally not not
personal slander at all so look you were
playing you got to play as a medic and
medic there's new medic class and as
opposed to the first medic which has
sort of a heel beam and is like the
active like sort of shadowing is more of
like a distance medics know you're
getting a cloaking device and you're
more of a range character and instead of
using the beam the heel beam which is
closed as you said you get a revived you
still have to be close to use your
revive but you only use it to bring
people back from the dead and you can do
that as many times as you want as long
as you do it with a certain amount of
time so it's a really important class
and you're kind of off in the distance
lofty almost like you would say the
Kraken yeah you want to stay away from
the action and like not get detected so
there's a silenced sniper rifle that
helps you not then not attract the
monsters attention but that that revived
is so key because it's
not the normal revive that you can do
just as anybody who can sort of come in
pick up an incapacitated player whenever
play a hunter's incapacitated they get a
strike against him and on the third
strike they die there's reno reviving
them but with that medics class that
strike does not count you don't they
don't get the incapacitation strike and
so i was watching you play and you are
like picking that assault up a bunch of
times and the assault is basically no
worse for wear because you can pick them
up do like a little burst heal and then
they're right back in the action unless
the monster spots you and like so that's
that's what they're coaching me right
and this is the way they do the demos
they coach you a little bit on strategy
because there's so much strategy in in
any given situation when you down
someone as the monster you got to be
watching out for the sneaky little medic
step I'm turn invisible who's gonna
tiptoe in you know it's dead here what
are you talking about you shot and
you're out and that's a really
interesting you know you have both of
these floaty characters you have the
Kraken who's floating in taking off a
bunch of shots and then getting out and
you've a medic exploding in secretly
reviving people and getting out so it's
a really nice dynamic of play there is a
lot of strategy involved and I think
it's just one more one more tick that
says that evolve is is wrapping up to be
a real good game it's really cool really
exciting to play I had a blast playing
sounds like you had a really good time
good oh I destroyed them all them I'm
just really nice spying uh if you guys
so this is if you guys want to know more
about the new hunters we've got previews
up to sort of delineate the differences
between the four previous characters
announced and the new for ones are
showing off at e3 we also have previews
it says a lot more about the Krakens you
can read that and check out the stage
demo when we had the assault class
actually demoed on our live stage see
some flamethrower action that's all up
on gamespot yeah that's pretty cool to
watch too so there'll be a lot more
coverage and more coming from here right
here at e3 2014 sh FF gamespot com